[Music]
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
talk about the universe
in art
in art yeah artists been touching the
universe lately and we're going to get
some insights well i've been doing it
for quite some time actually we'll get
some insights on that but let me first
introduce my co-host chuck nice jack hey
neil
jack all right i'm excited art and uh
the universe i feel as though i i should
be uh
conducting this show with a fine boredom
in my head
you know
so
actually at art openings they don't uh
they don't serve where do they serve
merlot at art or that's the that's the
journal oh how garish no
so um so that's the contract joe
six-pack and and martin merlot see
that's how that goes
yeah so uh actually you know i think a
lot about this stuff but i don't claim
any special expertise in it and so we've
got two guests who
are all in it uh let me first introduce
a long time friend and colleague and
fellow new yorker and i think we even
went to the same high school as each
other i've got jay pasikov jay welcome
to star talk well thank you very much
it's nice to see another bronx high
school of science alumnus again
okay
and you're the field memorial professor
of astronomy and your director of the
hopkins observatory at williams college
and i kind of sort of can claim i'm a
graduate because they uh
i i was honored by an honorary degree
several years back so thank you guys for
uh for voting a well-deserved honor
in the club in the car neil that would
only make you an honorary graduate so
damn just you know check
i worked hard for that honorary i sat by
the phone and they called me i'm like
you got enough degrees
it's better than being a dishonorary
graduate oh there you go all right
we've got with us an actual artist art
historian
and co-author of a couple of books with
jay roberta olsen roberta
welcome it's thrilling to be here neil
and you're actually a neighbor of
mine on central park west well there you
are as curator of drawings that's a
that's a cool thing on your card i
curate all drawings all attempts of
people to represent reality and all that
comes out of their head even if it's not
reality i guess
drawings at the new york historical
society across the street from the
american museum of natural history in
new york city you also professor
emeritus and i have actually written
books without jay but now it would be
very difficult
because we have forged such a wonderful
uh relationship and uh process of
looking at art and
representations of astronomical
phenomena
yeah because these the universe is quite
the fertile subject for
uh art and let me just finish out your
your cv here professor emeritus of art
history at wheaton college so that's the
full sort of ids for both of you that
that's great now the two books one of
them when i first knew of your
collaborations it was fire and ice a
history of comets in art uh and that's
still on my shelf and i loved that book
and that was only me
oh that was only you oh my god but it
was
before that um and it was actually that
that was the reason why jay and i met
so that that's the that's the origin
story
of your publishing relationship
wow wow
well okay so you've got so so okay so
you've already had some astronomy chops
is what you're saying here well i mean i
grew up in the middle midwest and so i
went out to look at the perseids on top
of you know uh trunks of cars and then
when i was teaching at wheaton college i
was doing a
two
week long sort of investigation of jotto
and i looked at the adoration of the
magi one time
jodo the artist
who painted the scrovenia chapel in
padua
and in
1303 to 1306
and i looked at the adoration of the
magi and i asked my class
why is there a comet for the star of
bethlehem
no one could answer so neat right
because if you draw the star of
bethlehem it's got like pointy pointy
uh
spikes coming out of it and if you draw
a comet people know what commas look
like you don't mistake a comet for a
star but you know what this is what's
absolutely incredible so i had to answer
my students you know i was a good
teacher i am a good teacher so i went to
the new york public library and i spent
months
learning commentology
also going through everything that had
been published on jotto
and ecclesiastes was actually wrong
no one had ever identified that as a
comet so i thought got to do something
about this
learn commentology and i thought
all the art publications
two years hence
so i sent it to scientific american
unknown
and
there were there were no computers in
those days this is 1979.
i got a letter back in two days and said
we're going to put it in the next issue
all right well there you go there it was
and then the european space agency sent
me a telegram oh those dinosaur days
and said
were flying to halley's comet
in 1985 86 can we name the satellite
chatter they asked me i mean
how humbling is that
saying we'll ask johno you know
yeah so neil remind me never to get into
an argument with roberta
roberta is just like i'll see you in two
years
after i learn everything about it and
you sir will be proven wrong no but
at the time this is we're talking about
1979 there wasn't that much published i
mean it's very different we are filled
with wonderful things today but a glut
of information and in those days it was
much more manageable
and uh wait but you're leaving out an
important piece of information here if
you do this 75 76 year
orbit of comet halle and you go
backwards through time it lands
at the time
that
painting was made isn't that correct so
we can say that was probably halley's
comment absolutely
correct and we know from giovanni
villani's chronicle it was described
exactly
like
jotto painted it and he has the
wonderful sweeping dust tail he does it
in layers he has the condensation around
the nucleus and the coma i mean it's
absolutely brilliant layer upon layer
and
it actually is artists are very
intelligent they layer things
and he put it
where the star of bethlehem usually is
but someone was advising him and he did
his church fathers he read origen and
john of damascus because they describe
the star of bethlehem in words that
you neil you chuck you jay everyone will
look at and say yes that's a comet he's
describing not a star
yeah yeah
yeah because the you know we all share
the same vocabulary and if you're
looking at stuff it's going to come out
that way so this latest collaboration is
uh let me make sure i get the title of
that jay what's the title of the book
well the latest collaboration is cosmos
the art and science of the universe
but it started with halley's comet
uh a mutual colleague
the late sam edgerton the professor of
art at williams invited roberta to come
up from
up to give a lecture and i went to her
lecture
and i heard that the first two-thirds of
her lecture and the first two-thirds of
my hallie's comment lecture were similar
but of course her last third was art and
mine was
science and we were introduced at that
point
so basically since halley's comet came
by in 1985
we've been we've been working together
so what can the two of you say or
reflect upon
when you see artists reach for the
universe as their sources of inspiration
well it's really uh an exploration again
um and again multi-leveled artists are
are basically searchers for meaning just
like astronomers i mean it's a different
thing plus both artists and astronomers
are visual
and it depends on what area you're
talking about if you're talking about um
babylonian seal engravers they were
reflecting the cosmology at the time and
the belief in astrology if you're
talking about the 18th century in
england this was a time when people were
really differentiating what was going on
in the heavens and
scientists
astronomers and amateurs and
professionals and artists were both
involved with with uh sort of describing
what they could see because that was a
different universe than we have today in
the sense of what could be encompassed
right but it's one thing it's one thing
to interpret the universe and then
create some work of art that emanates
from your own
uh perspective it's another thing
because i don't know how to draw and i
need you to draw what i see in my
telescope so you're kind of a substitute
uh camera for me in that context so
do you guys explore that distinction
and before photography that was the case
and in fact if you know carolyn herschel
she drew
uh comments uh in her book of records we
know that actually newton
um sir isaac newton drew
comets uh in his scribblings too
and in his notes astronomers actually
and some of the wonderful mcclear have
fabulous drawings because before
uh
before photography you had to be able to
draw to remember something to describe
something because art is a
visual language and so you have that but
then art is also a symbolic image and so
if we jump to the fact of the universe
is riveting okay comets are riveting the
stars are riveting and they also
shall we say call forth speculation uh
where are we going where have we been
where are we going to as gauguin would
say
they encourage speculative thought plus
before electricity
they were much more galvanizing i don't
know if you tried to see comet near wise
last year yes it did of course yeah i
did too who you think you're talking who
why do you think you're talking to it
did i see a comet
well i i had to sort of tweak you a
little bit on that one okay
yeah
but so one of the questions you're
asking neil is
is when did people really
draw
what they
what they saw so one of the first things
that i did with roberta was when we
noticed that in a book called the
nuremberg chronicle from 1492
there were a number of pictures of
comets but one of them kept getting
cited as the first drawing of uh of a
comet and when we actually looked in the
book and this at that time and free
world wide web required my going to the
harvard library to take the book out and
and and page through we discovered about
a dozen pictures of comets but then we
realized that there were only four
woodcuts
and they turned them every which way
and just put them next to dates
so uh so that was not really a picture
of it was an independent drawing oh my
god it was just it was stylized wood
cuts and so we just we heard that there
were exemplars which are plans for the
books you know layouts which were very
racial shay and had been lost in world
war ii
and we were able to go to nuremberg
because the library had found them
and see how they plotted out both the
latin first and then the german editions
in 1493. it was just
fabulous
well so just remind me the nuremberg
chronicles is a complete compilation of
all knowledge
up to that date isn't that correct
that's right if i remember that's right
and it's an early and canonical it's
very important um and it's a huge volume
but they tried to give the entire
history of the world in terms of you
know rulers and war everything
everything it was just yeah that was
that one-stop shop
and it was really good i have to say
but they've reused woodcuts some of the
pictures of
cities uh were reused from one one city
to a different city and we then did make
this list in an article we had a grant
from the travel
for collections from the national
endowment for the humanities to go see
these exemplars and they turned out to
be really sketchy just very rough pencil
drawings so there was clearly no
accuracy in the depiction of the comets
at all
you know with respect to that are there
times when uh as roberta uh mentioned
earlier
the speculative nature where we're going
what we're doing which often leads to
interpretation and the artist being able
to expand what they're looking at so
that's what that's what i want an artist
to do for me
right
quick because jay i get i get people
write to me and say oh i saw this hubble
photo and i made this painting of the
hubble photo
i'm sorry i don't need that i got the
hubble photo all right so so where
at what point did artists start
putting their own paw print
on
on the cosmic topic well in fact i think
one of the reasons that the hubble
photos are so interesting to many people
is that they have a public information
division that colorizes the photos in
weird and wonderful ways
and have paid a lot of attention to the
artistic
uh
versions so so in fact i'd be very glad
to have an oil painting
uh of one of the hubble photos on my
wall if any of the listeners here want
to send us some
some copies
maybe uh three three copies please one
to roberta one to neil and one to me
um we have these these wonderful false
color things and now we're looking
forward to the false color things
that'll come out of the james webb space
telescope when that's launched uh in a
few months and that in fact is just
going to work in the infrared as
certainly neil knows very well
so there won't actually be the same high
quality
fine resolution visible light photos but
in false color it'll it'll all look
great and we just have to hope that we
get these pictures down
and jay let me just thank you for
leaving me off the list as i now sit
without any hubble oil paintings
[Music]
perhaps he'll keep it at the museum and
i can see it there well i actually have
one page on my wall from the nuremberg
chronicle that happens to have a comet
in it of course so i'll make a copy of
that chuck if you send me your address
thanks for watching i'll get you that
copy uh thank you thank you so much and
jay you own so many antiquarian books
i'm disappointed you don't have your own
nurbur chronicles
uh there was uh a choice at one point
through getting the nuremberg chronicle
or
or or getting something that was more
straightforward astronomy and i i got
the astronomy one but i'm so sorry that
i let the nuremberg chronicle get away
yeah i thought you might have said i
could have bought the nurber chronicle
or another house
[Laughter]
last i checked what these things are
going for we're going to take a break
we're going to take a break when we come
back
more
with
jay and roberta jake jay pasigoff
roberta olsen we're talking about
the history of astronomy and art on star
talk
we're back star talk i got chuck nice my
co-host chuck what's your what's your
social media handle uh chuck nice
comment thank you for asking neil there
you go there you go and i'm sorry you
don't know it uh
but i appreciate you allowing me to call
it out
it's better in your voice that's why i
did that and
did you get roberta's permission to use
the word comment in your
hand
apparently roberta trademark comments uh
we've got roberta olsen art historian
publication for sure okay so we'll talk
about that
roberta olsen art historian and jay
pasikov a fellow astrophysicist and
they're collaborators on
on projects that explore the
intersection of art and science and
roberta we left off you were going to
tell us
when and where or how artists started
making
representations of the universe
an expression of their how they see the
world rather than
trying to duplicate what a photograph
might do okay well i think it starts
first of all trying to capture uh in the
renaissance what people saw for example
the lorenzetti would look at meteor
showers and put them in the garden of
gethsemane when christ was arrested and
judas betrayed him because it was chaos
it was a symbol but it was a symbol
everyone could understand because they
had seen it they were afraid when they
were meteors falling um so that was a
symbol everyone understood and then i
think by the time you go but just to be
clear at the time they had no clue what
a meteor was so these are just these are
just falling stars stars but it's they
didn't know whether they were comets or
meteors or whatever they were not
differentiated until the 18th century
really so they were called things like
falling stars broom stars hairy stars
and comey taste by the way is greek for
harry starr
which is why they were always satirized
with long trusses but then in the eighth
century
after the enlightenment had set in when
it was sort of everyone had mastered
depictions that were realistic
artists
and also writers began to be very
subjective and i mean you always had
comets and meteors and other
astronomical things used by shakespeare
by spencer and they had all this
incredible symbolic baggage
artists began trying to express what
they felt about
life the universe their own
view of things like william blake who
holds the record of showing 18 comets in
his illustrations and they're bizarre as
i'll get out
very personal um it was sort of a
liberation and then the same that's how
i that's what i want if i had a house
artist that's what i'd want them to do
you know like the king has it has like a
court jester and of course if i had a
artist at my disposal i'd want them to
always interpret the world for me yeah
that's and it's great and it's it's uh
endless like the universe i mean it can
go on i mean obviously everyone has a a
finite number of years but they were
very inventive i mean it was something
that people had fun with they also
became uh
vehicles for satirizing in the
18th century when you had
coffee houses and they would have
caricatures of people you could do
political caricatures you could do uh
anything but remember these were topical
events
okay everybody looked up there was the
sky
there was no tv there were no computers
and this and everything that happened in
the sky was much brighter and people
were still afraid
so the sky was
the sky is uh antiquities television
yeah basically yeah and
up until electricity it was and then you
had people in the victorian times they
would take transparencies and they would
take pins and prick them and put them up
to their kerosene lamps to try to
duplicate what they had seen in the
heavens but it was okay i i just got to
say this i don't know if people are
paying attention here but roberta took
us from ancient babylon in the beginning
right
up to the roman empire and christ right
up to the
1700s how much
where where how much history is in you
know she went then she went up to the
victorians
yes okay there's just endless amount of
material i mean thousands and thousands
and thousands of works that we could
discuss
and roberta knows them all so so
so that so that's what this new book is
basically we've written a dozen or
whatever articles over the over
centali's comet came by
in 1985-86
and so we just had a chance that we have
a dozen chapters each on a different
topic eclipses meteors
comments uh etc in in this uh new book
with a lot of with a a few hundred
illustrations uh showing samples from
all these different periods of time
so chuck when you said she knows
thousands of years i was to say we need
a bigger boat or a bigger bigger format
but so roberta i've i've done some a
little bit of my own homework nothing i
wouldn't call it scholarly homework but
just sort of casual homework while i'm
you know
eating popcorn and
uh
van gogh's starry night the starry night
1889
i've looked hard and i've not been able
to find another work of art
where the title
is astronomical
even if there's astronomical things in
the painting not only that it's the i
have not been able to find
a work of art where
the title is the background
so he's got he's got a village he's got
rolling hills there's a cypress tree
none of that is the title of that
painting
it's called the starry night
so
for me it
felt like
maybe
the universe is becoming front and
center and not just the wallpaper or
whatever else you're drawing
so
how much of what i just told you there
will land on fertile ground and how much
is just [ __ ] and remember he's not
the least bit biased
van gogh speaks to you and threw you in
because
what he has shown is an approximation of
his emotional uh interaction with the
universe there are other works of art
with titles that have um
astronomical features such as melees um
work that's not starring i thought it's
the same thing it's a meteor shower
which van gogh may have known
um but i think that ben go was totally
obsessed you know he did at least four
people
the crowning one of it and that he
actually wrote at least four where the
night sky is with the night sky and
actually one uh an additional one which
people haven't commented on which is
known in about four versions so there
are five with one or four versions
and we're very lucky because he wrote to
his brother theo and told him everything
and he told him that he wanted to do
a painting of the starry night
and nocturnes were very very popular at
this point in uh paris and all over in
england as well
um and he but nocturnes i think of
nocturnes i think of uh piano nocturnes
is that what you mean or something else
nocturne is a term for a knight painting
and uh
something done at night and we know that
he warmed up to this and in fact he
wrote to his friend the belgian
eugene bloch that he wanted to paint
this cafe terrace where they had been
that was the first one and he painted
the sky at the cafe by the way is now
named cafe van gogh it wasn't at the
time but everyone goes there on the van
gogh tour uh to see it
and the second warm-up was the one that
is um
shall we say uh
over the rome it's uh
uh the view over the rhone with the
starry sky and it's very near where he
was living in all at the time he was
living in the yellow house
and
that one actually does have
uh
astronomical bodies you can't identify
it has part of the ursa major
the big bear the part that the english
called the plow and we call the big
dipper
and
but it's reoriented it's a marriage it's
not an actual topographical shall we say
or
skyscape view because he's looking
towards the southwest and you can by
going there you can figure out where the
view was because it looks very much the
same and there are pictures of it
he was actually painting the sky in the
other side so he married the two and
this sort of answers many of your
questions i mean he lied just to say
good luck
you could say
come on artistic devices
okay okay jay likes that it's artistic
license he manipulated things for
feelings he wanted things and he wrote
to his brother
after starry night he wrote i'm in dire
need of religion
for him if you think of starry night you
think of the blues he equated colors
with certain emotions okay this is
post-impressionism blue was infinity
blue was eternity and he's speculating
just like you do when you look through a
telescope
what's out there what does it mean okay
where are we going um how does it relate
to me and people have spilled much ink
about what we see in the sky the only
thing we can say for certain is that
there is what he called the morning star
which was venus which apparently
according to astronomical uh
calculations was in its
eighth year of the cycle so it was
extremely strong but he distorts
everything for a kind of wonderful
oriole this glow around the morning star
and then
maybe you can tell me neil and they
certainly can comment and i'm sure chuck
could too
is that the spiral nebula or some people
said oh no it's clouds in the mistral
and then down below on the horizon
is that the milky way and then we have a
crescent moon but we know this painting
was done in two days
it was done um
in two days we know that from the
letters to theo
and the moon was gibbous at that point
it wasn't a crescent so he's
you'd say he's lying he's manipulating
it because you know the crescent moon is
more interesting for most people who are
not astronomers okay yeah people hardly
ever draw a gibbous moon it's just it's
the saddest moon phase of them all i
know it's not a full moon and it's not a
crescent like what is that
i remember astronomy at this time was
very popular in france you had
flammarion and you heard guillermo and
flammarion
because he was so parapathetic we don't
know what van gogh saw but for instance
gustav monroe who's but just be clear
camille flamer a
highly prolific
french writer of astronomical but pop
french writer of astronomical subjects
everyone got it and but he had beautiful
illustrations in his book as well
we know for example a contemporary uh
gustaf marrow who has all this library
preserved in italian which you can visit
in paris
had copies of plumeria
okay so probably he thought could he
have seen
drawings of of laura ross uh of his
spiral nebula he made it per castle
they were published now all of this
ah and this is what makes art so
fascinating it's not a simple answer and
to unravel it you have to do
archaeology of all sorts like jay and i
know we got um getty grants to do our
our book fire in the sky comets and
meteors of decisive century and british
art and science
you have to go to the place and you have
to find things that have never been
published and it's a uh
shall we say a voyage of discovery i
mean put it in your terms for your
is it a voyage of discovery it is is it
archaeology yes but it's finding things
that haven't been there before so that
you understand what the artist was
exposed to an artist is like a sponge
they take in all this stuff
and they
create something that is entirely
different entirely their own and you may
relate to it in certain ways i may
relate to it in certain ways and then
there are the givens
right can you comment on the intensity
of van gogh's colors
it's been rumored that he might have had
some synesthesia i think it's called
where
you hear you can hear color
you know your senses are cross-wired so
that it may have manifested differently
or more intensely within him and because
people always remark on the on the
intensity of those colors it's almost
psychedelic it is psychedelic and in
fact he purposely chose complementary
colors like oranges and yellows with
blues and greens and then in the night
cafe
um and by the way i should say something
about gaslight he does the same thing
with gaslight that he does with with
venus the morning star he makes it
vibrate though it's alive
because for him it's an emotional thing
gaslight was new and he wanted to
juxtapose in the cafe with the terrace
the new gas light
with the cosmic light wow um
and
before you go any further uh roberta pbs
just called and said we have enough for
the special
that's right
we all sign up for the class we all got
it amazing it's amazing
um i just read you a quote
about the uh the cafe the night cafe
which is at yale which is all
complimentary's yellow and um
actually green and red with some yellow
in it and i remember always teaching my
students and say you don't want to stay
in there you go in that cafe where he
always ate cafe de la gab you go in the
cafe and you run out but this is what he
said
in my picture of the night cafe i have
tried to express the idea that that cafe
is a place where one can ruin oneself
go mad or commit a crime
and then he says about the colors to
answer chuck
all in an atmosphere like a devil's
furnace of pale sulfur
whoo
that's amazing wow so he was at a biker
bar basically that's really
bad stuff going on he wanted to hype
everything up
um i mean wait wait chuck i thought you
don't see color i thought
this is true neil i'm not that kind of
person
maybe artistically maybe that's the only
way i will see
right now now jay i ran some numbers on
the starry night with the crescent moon
so according to roberta they know when
it was painted and of course we would
know the phase of the moon trivially
upon getting the date however
if we assume if instead of that you say
okay here's the crescent moon here's
venus the morning star at about that
angle to each other
and about that elevation above the
horizon i derived a date for that scene
and it's june 21st 1889. and so
and the fact that venus and the moon are
at that very low angle to each other
betrays the fact that he's at a very
high northern latitude so all of that
sort of makes sense and i'm i'm
wondering
maybe it didn't matter when he painted
it he saw that crescent moon and venus
at some other date it would have to have
been june 21st and it put it in his
painting
well there's there's another olson and i
never get confused between roberta olsen
and don olson oh donaldson at texas
the texas tech uh actually uses all
those uh positions of things
and and goes to the places with his
students and figures out exactly when
and exactly where
uh people were standing and and what
direction they're looking at uh and he's
got a couple of books out about that
that are very interesting
but the work with roberta's is more uh
is more art historical rather than
rather than positional
positional technical right right right
yes but we know that he painted this on
june 19th and worked on it for two days
and interestingly it's at the museum of
modern normal that would be a crescent
moon wait wait if you if that's the date
it was a crescent it wasn't gibbous it
was crescent moon i promise
you yeah then the literature is bomb
neal send me what program did you use
and that's the wonderful thing about
computers you can
program you can program eclipse pass
right right and and i agree that nobody
paints hardly anybody paints gibbous
moons it's a sad
phase but the face i learned from a
colleague a few years ago that it's
called gibbous because it give us more
light
when you combine high tech with
illiteracy you get very you get
fascinating
you know that they examine the canvas
though and they they said it's two days
he left holes in the canvas
where he
put in the astronomical phenomena he
painted the foreground first
and the cypress tree which of course is
a symbol of
a cemetery and death as well as being
evergreen and notice how the cypress
tree dominates nature dominates
completely
completely and
in a sense it it unifies heaven and
earth it is the cosmos because if you
think of humboldt on humboldt and the
cosmos it also takes us down to earth
it's the entire
whole
working universe
so for those who didn't know i mean on
von humboldt
was one of the first
people to
bring some intellectual harmonization
to the fields of study of our place on
earth and in the universe
you know before that was this little
thing going on over there and this is
happening over here and this is
happening on earth and he's saying maybe
it's all part of one thing that we might
call nature
so
uh yeah i mean people like that are are
not as much talked about because you
can't point to the one thing they
discovered that changed things but they
he introduced a perspective that surely
had deep influence uh culturally and i
keep running into his name all over
anyway thank you thank you so much for
inviting us to be on star talk
today yeah this is this is this has been
great so chuck you're right the pbs did
call i got the text from them they
wanted to the three-part special
streaming
and roberta we're all gonna uh you're
gonna do a master class on this and
we're all gonna sign up for it for sure
great well it's been a delight to be
with you
yeah and so roberta thank you roberta
olsen and jay pasikov and uh you guys
and your latest book
where can we find it i guess just just
uh amazon or
who's the publisher it's reaction in
london and it's on amazon and it's in
many bookstores
and the university of chicago press is
the american distributor the american
distributor okay
give you lots of quotes from people and
and uh also a sample of the text
yeah and my website at
solarcorona.com
has a link to it i see what you did
there because what i didn't say in this
program is
jay pasikov
he he's got to be up there among
people who spent the most time in an
eclipse shadow
right you got to be top 10 of all time
jay are you monitoring this
uh i i monitor the numbers other people
monitor the time it's it's a lot of fun
we're looking forward to how many
eclipses have you seen 73.
that's crazy crazy and how many of those
have you looked at like donald trump
[Laughter]
you know where you just stare directly
into it
you spend a lot of time trying to
educate people about how to observe
eclipses
fantastic
so i've been delighted to have you guys
on and maybe we can do something like
this again we'll find some other art
topics that are would be in desperate
need of illumination
by you both sounds like fun okay so uh
we're gonna take a quick break and when
we come back we're gonna analyze the
neuroscience
of art or what's going on in our brains
when we do art and when we think about
art when star talk continues
we're back star talk i have a new guest
for this segment chuck it's old time
favorite of star talk yes it's a new
guess but frequent guest notice i didn't
say new guest but old guests
[Laughter]
yes
heather in the house heather berlin
welcome back to star talk you're such a
friend of our show thanks for doing this
every time we call on you of course
always a pleasure yeah and so just get
your title a neuroscientist which is
what just really just what i want to
call you but you have other titles
clinical psychologist and professor of
psychiatry at the ikah
i can i know i can't yeah i knew it was
coming
i see ahn icon school of medicine at
mount sinai and so just welcome back
because we're talking about what's going
on inside the brain when we
think about art and when we do art and
so what's going on
what what's happening when an artist is
creating
in this way in their brains
well you know there's this old myth that
i just want to get right off the bat
debunk that you know creativity comes
from the right side of the brain and
sort of science and reasoning and logic
on the left side so that's old news um
but when people are being creative
there's but you're saying it's old news
that it's bs or it's old news that it's
what is the old news part of it oh so
there's certain what we call
lateralization of function which just
means that
certain functions are more specialized
in one part of the area of the brain
than another so language tends to be
more on the left but there's also some
language areas on the right
okay and so there is some of that
specialization of function between
hemispheres but
this idea that all of creativity comes
from the right side of the brain it's
basically that's not how it works it's
not how it works is that how it works
there's a network in the brain there's
something called the default mode
network
which is active when we are sort of
focused inward when we're daydreaming
when we're mind wandering when we're not
thinking about anything specific and
that's sort of where the creative juices
come from bubble up from
oh the default
oh my god that actually sounds like a
tiny little hole in the back of your
neck that you stick a paper clip and it
resets you to factory settings
that's not too far off it's kind of like
when you go back to your baseline to
your basic brain state
when you're not taking in any
information from the world that can kind
of muddy the waters in a way
and then you stay there for a bit and
then there's something called the
salience network another kind of
activation network in the brain that
tells you what's important to pay
attention to at any given
point in time so it'll either tell you
you can just go back to your default
mode and hang out there or there's
something happening in the environment
you should switch your focus of
attention outward and when it tells you
to do that you go into what's called the
central executive network or the
executive control network which is
looking out at the environment it's more
sort of logic reason
um but you can switch back and forth
between these networks so we find that
when people are in the creative process
they're going um between this default
mode network where ideas are bubbling up
but then you have to do something with
them you have to enact them you have to
give them some structure so it's almost
like default mode network is like being
in an unorganized sort of dream state
where anything goes you can make novel
associations between ideas that's where
creation can you fly can i even fly you
can even fly thank you i believe you can
fly
you can fly
but then you have to kick in the sort of
more rational logical um
parts of the brain that can organize it
and structure it so the process of
creativity is switching between these
networks and we find in our imaging
studies that more creative people have
more connectivity between these networks
so they can switch in and out of them
quicker
do they suffer anywhere because of the
greater connectivity between a good
question yeah what yeah what's the cost
what's the cost of that yes
because because if you connect to the
dream state easily
maybe
you're not fully connected to the real
world at times when you might need to be
or at least that's what i'm hoping
[Laughter]
that's
trying to account for your own state of
existence
well i mean on the on the plus side
people are creative tend to have more
flexibility more adaptability um
if you were to always stay in that sort
of default mode network and have trouble
switching states you would have problems
right that's people with schizophrenia
who can't get out of that kind of a
state um but in terms of the
relationship
between sort of let's say mental health
issues and creativity again that's
another myth that's been debunked
there's not it's not any more
significant um there's nothing more
prevalent of
mental health disorders and creative
people compared to the rest of the
population so we like to point to these
particular cases that stand out but
that's very anecdotal on average artists
aren't necessarily more
dysfunctional than your average you know
wall street guy well i'm going to have
to look for another excuse
excuse me yeah
wait so so heather are these
literal electrochemical networks in the
brain or is this an organizing
uh
is this an organizing
uh sort of heuristic accounting
of what we see going on
i think it's a little of both but it's
it's certainly um
there are these networks that we all
have in our brains that are going to be
either
active activated or deactivated
depending on what we're doing
but imagine the future where you find
you know where that network is and you
go with some needle and inject it with
extra electrochemical nodes and then all
of a sudden a person gets more creative
if you can actually know and identify
and isolate such networks in the brain
but
yeah i was just going to say this
as a person who
dabbles in creativity
you can actually do that kind of to
yourself right now
you know there are times when you can
i can't say make yourself more creative
but there are times that you can deepen
the creative mode there are times when
you can actually do activities to place
your mind and to receive creativity no
chuck i want heather to inject a joke in
your head or something okay that's what
i want heather
you know she's working on that wait a
minute
let me just say this neil i want heather
to attempt
you see behind that screen behind her
there see that's that's on that screen
so heather a very very serious question
let's look at uh
you know van gogh of course was an
impressionist artist but let's let's
back up a little and let's go to
leonardo so leonardo is illustrating
perfectly
human physiology in his artwork
where is the creativity in that if he is
only drawing what he sees
that was a good one wouldn't it wow
so in a way i wouldn't call that part of
his uh
output the most creative part the
creativity was in his drawings of like
flying machines and
he's he's thinking way the way no one
has thought before right doing detailed
anatomy is talent for sure right but i
wouldn't say that is the most creative
aspect of um leonardo and and
you know what we see is that when people
are in these really highly creative
states
we're seeing these differences in
network activation but then we can also
pinpoint certain just like nodes within
that network that if we kind of focus in
on those that maybe we could stimulate
creativity or or decrease creativity but
one of them is the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex which we find when
it's turned down people tend to be more
creative and in these flow states and
when it's turned
up they tend to be more self-aware
self-conscious and less
creative
so by creativity you mean a new idea
yeah a new novel so we all have access
to the same information
um i like to use darwin as an example
like we all all the scientists time had
access to that basic data
but he kind of put that data together in
a novel way which when when they come up
with it it seems of course obvious it's
just that nobody else had thought of
that before and so it's novel thinking
it's divergent thinking new associations
between ideas when everybody had access
to the same information
so it's so funny you say that uh
when comedians watch each other work the
thing that they'll do is they'll sit
there and they'll go oh that was funny
oh that's funny they never laugh and the
reason is because they're watching that
person make associations that they
themselves did not make and so they're
thinking like oh wow i didn't even look
at it that way
so if if that's the case if it's
creativity is a great has a great deal
to do with associations like darwin same
information making new associations
will ai
be able to be more creative than human
beings because ai is able to make
millions of associations at once
so there well first of all there's been
some studies with comedians which look
at amateur versus professional um when
they have to look at a cartoon and then
the task was just come up with a novel
like uh you know creative punch line to
this cartoon like a new yorker cartoon
and um
it takes less work for the professional
comedians to activate to come up with
something and we find that the
association areas um are more quickly
activated so you're quicker to make
these associations now with ai um
i just recently came across this video
that was the first comedy set that was
created by an ai i i will send out the
link i encourage you to watch it please
simultaneously awkward yet strangely
funny in a weird awkward way i i i will
send you the link out the link are you
sure somebody didn't just tape my set
sounds a lot like
weirdly awkwardly funny chucks really
awkwardly funny
comfortable uneasy way you know that
they say that uncanny valley right when
you are trying to create the ai things
there's just something slightly off
that's what it's like with the comedy
but however i do i do think that after
they perfect it and after they you know
keep feeding in this algorithm over and
over again with self-learning processes
that they will be able to come up with
these novel jokes and to rival you know
the greatest comedians so
so heather let me ask uh there's been
rumors that
van gogh may have had a
uh
i don't say suffered from because that
places value judgment on it but had a
condition of synesthesia or chromosis
there's been rumors about that i guess
where you hear color right yeah or you
smell color
where there's a cross wiring of your
senses right right right so
any
um what can you tell us about those two
conditions within the human mind well
chromeesthesia is like a subset of
synesthesia which is sort of crossing
over of the senses so sometimes people
will see
um letters as different colors or
numbers as different colors um and they
will cross over chrome esthesia
specifically sounds relating to colors
so colors will sound like something um
so if you imagine a van the dutch would
say van gaach but van gogh uh for the
english speaking people which i am one
um they imagine his painting would sound
musical to him it would be like a
symphony made up of colors um there's
some there's some speculation that he
had this
because of the letters he had written to
his brother theo yeah in fact i have a
note here it says uh quoting van gogh in
a letter to his brother theo so it says
here some artists have a nervous hand at
drawing
which gives their technique something of
the sound peculiar to a violin
how could you even write that
unless there was some cross wiring in
your brain
exactly that's what i'm thinking that's
what i'm thinking and it's not just in
terms of what's happening in the brain
it's not there's one idea that it's a
sort of
cross wiring um another is that
there is this disinhibition of feedback
so a reduction normally we're having
lots of information coming out of the
brain and parts of it have to inhibit
information from crossing over but when
you lift that um
inhibition
you can get these you know
melding of senses and you can actually
induce synesthesia in people people who
have certain types of strokes or
temporal lobe epilepsy or then with
drugs like psychedelics when you
lift the constraints of the brain which
we normally need the constraints to be
able to function but when you lift the
constraints that's when you can get
these hallucinations and these blending
of the senses and there's a paper i read
years ago it was in the american journal
psychology psychiatry in 2002
that um has a theory that van gogh
actually had temporal lobe epilepsy he
was having epileptic seizures they think
were induced by absinthe
um and those seizures might have
actually been related to the um
chromesthesia but other people are born
with it too so it could be it's a
genetic there's a genetic um there's
some inheritance with this as well what
you were really trying to tell us is
that van gaal was
high and tripping
[Laughter]
you might say or others might say he
just had a secret window into the
reality that we all are you know being
constrained
wow good reply there
he has access to doorways that the rest
of us don't
so so is is the transition from
representational art to
impressionist art is that a creative
leap
or is it was or was is the first artist
to do that just lazy
i'm just wondering i mean i don't mean
you know i you know i don't mean
disrespect yeah i don't mean any
disrespect but
did they just say
i'm just gonna you know
i'm not i'm not gonna paint every leaf
on this tree
yeah yeah my theory is that they were
all nearsighted so
also everything was blurry
right
the nearsighted painting painters
movement right you know i dare say and
as someone who does paints and who has
trained um in paint i was a fine arts
minor and i painted i do know that we
have to get trained in all of the skill
sets first you have to be you know
perfect the actual representational
before you can go into the abstract i do
think it was a creative leap because you
know it was something new it was
something different it was a new way to
perceive the world and now we're getting
into the realm in you know current um
art theory where it becomes so abstract
that like
you know there was a recently a
sculpture that was put out there an
invisible sculpture it's just a pedestal
a pedestal i read about that with
nothing on it with nothing on it and
it's invisible sculpture and then it was
crazy as another guy said oh you stole
my idea that was my
my invisible mind
my invisible sculpture yeah it came
first
um but but it's become an abstraction
now where it's not even about the art
and they're still of course you know
realist painters out there well wait did
they steal that from john cage who has
he has a piano sonata
was it it's just called 411 or something
which is like the minutes and seconds i
forgot there's some duration and the
penis just sits there
and just
yes their hands hover over the keys and
they never they don't do anything and
the claim is if you do this in a theater
then the concert is basically the sound
of the audience
right
the sound of silence is the sound of the
audience rustling and you know clearing
their throat and so that's the acoustic
version of the invisible sculpture and
let me just say this and heather what
the hell part of the brain comes up with
that right
well that's some creativity and that is
that's the that's the greedy part
because
you're charging money you stealing money
is what you're doing okay so chuck the
day you can pull off a comedy act you
just stand there and with your mouth
open and nothing coming out at the
microphone well the people that would
make people happy neil
right now we got to call heather quick
on that okay get a heather intervention
figure out how to how that one worked
guys we're running out of time but this
has been great heather thanks for
bringing some neuroscientific insights
to add to our artistic our artistic and
scientific insights into the mind of
vincent van gaal
this is america jack
i'm not
here and that's why we don't say it like
that it was just like oh i'm so sorry i
didn't mean to spit on you i'm so
in the time of coved you no longer in
the time of cobra
you got it well heather delight always
to have you on the show thanks for being
such a good sport every time we call you
for our emergency neuroscientific
inquiries
and chuck always good to have you
chuck nice comic on twitter and and
heather where where you at
heather underscore berlin and my website
is heatherberlin.com
excellent excellent okay guys so uh this
has been the conclu we now just
concluded our three-part investigation
into uh impressionist art focusing on
rango and of course my favorite of his
is the starry night
of course
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always i bid you
to keep looking up
[Music]